[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for example I was watching the show
Lucifer yeah I was watching Lucifer it's
a good show
and then I hit the button and it said
Satan moves to Los Angeles and
immediately finds it too dark and
depressing and I was watching I was
watching the show how to get away with
murder a lot of people look yeah how to
get away with murder
and I hit the info button that said if
you really want to know turn to channel
43 for the people Jason I was watching
this show called property brothers one
of those home sales shows called
property brothers yeah
and then I hit the info button and it
said couples pretend to be interested in
the house while secretly angling for a
four-way
[Applause]
that's what's going on Hollywood game
night I was watching Hollywood game
night look like fun Hollywood game night
then I hit the button and if said
celebrities have a choice rehab or this
show no rehab for me
I was watching Mozart in the jungle
Mozart in the jungle and I hit the info
button after one a bunch of Golden
Globes remember how you were going to
watch it yeah that didn't happen never
did pull her house I was watching fuller
house yeah gonna hit the info button a
family of grateful actors say their
lines between sighs of relief the golf
fix that's on the Golf Channel the golf
fix watch it for a little while get the
info button hey we didn't realize how
hard will be to fill an entire network
with golf stuff got an idea
shoot it send it to us we'll air it
whatever do something yeah
jeopardy I was watching jeopardy mustnít
for a little bit then I hit the e button
professorial host makes contestants feel
like idiots for not getting answers he
just learned at rehearsal
like NCIS NCIS yeah
watching it for a bit then I hit the
info button the number one show among
the coveted 68 to death demographic and
finally The Bachelor I was watching The
Bachelor watching for a bit I hit the
button that said the competition heats
up between 16 hopeful strains of
Chlamydia
[Applause]
you